and the person who actually what they're
assuming based on somebody's text thread
that was there apparently cuevo and uh
take off
they don't ever just go in into a place
by themselves yeah like I'm not sure if
they're highly Affiliated or Atlanta
just watches their back yeah but it's
said or uh basically kind of proposed to
believe that takeoff was actually shot
by one of cuevos people because in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast hope you're having a
lovely Sunday for those of you
non-believers out there this is your
church now you're going to hell but I'm
okay with that just kidding you're fine
you're fine you're fine I love you
um
so obviously things have been popping
off I feel like every time we do a
podcast there's some crazy [ __ ] going on
every time without fail yeah everybody
just be [ __ ] dying
this year a lot of [ __ ] rappers have
been dying yeah a lot of rappers I don't
know who they are but you know just
because of how digital music has been
been able to be passed out in processed
because of Spotify right A lot of these
kids like I don't know who they are but
they have millions and millions of spins
yeah I know man I there's a bunch of
rappers that I've never heard of who are
apparently popular in some form or shape
and I'm like who the [ __ ] is this person
or who who the [ __ ] is this group and
it's just like crazy man even the people
whose name I've I know I might have
heard their music in passing yeah I
don't necessarily know who they are
right right like so some of those songs
if you ask me oh Who's the artist like
who sings that song Or raps that song I
wouldn't be able to tell you I might
recognize this song like yeah I've heard
that song before and I and I know on
some level that it's popular but but I
don't know who the [ __ ] the artist is
yeah yeah because let's see if we we're
turning into Boomers bro
see I don't even know if it's because
we're Boomers or it's just because of
how like the radio doesn't control music
anymore yeah of course right so there's
so many different artists because before
there's certain artists that people
would just push on you right so a lot of
people don't understand is like you know
a lot of people who got radio spins was
because of money they would pay radio
stations they would get aiola man and
and basically that's how they would get
spins and you can create these artists
but nowadays it's like it started with
SoundCloud yeah uh band camp yeah and
then now and you know obviously before
that it was Myspace yeah Myspace before
that was you like hip-hop yeah exactly
out the trunk of the car you know the
burn CDs yeah you sling those mixtapes
um and some of them were literally tapes
right that's that's where the term
mixtape comes from yep
um but yeah it's definitely evolved into
something completely different nowadays
and and that's why it's so hard to get
familiarized with some of these artists
because you know we're we're adults now
and we're busy we don't have the same
amount of time that we used to have
where we can consume music because I
used to love discovering new artists and
just yeah just digging for music but now
it's just like I don't have too much
time or energy to dedicate towards
something like that and then because
there's a platform where these artists
can just pretty much Market themselves
and and build themselves you know
following through no major backing
whatsoever it's hard to keep up man
there's just way too many who's the uh
Who's the artist that uh that passed
away uh he was killed at a Roscoe's out
in Compton
if I put Roscoe's Roscoe's rapper dead
Roscoe's dead rapper which is so
insensitive but that's just I mean it's
almost a guaranteed it was pnb Rock oh
yeah pnb Rock I heard a couple of songs
but I can't I don't know the names but I
know he's that popular because I've
heard of him I I you know what prior to
us talking about it I never even heard
of him crazy right I can't name a single
song of his
but apparently he was popular enough for
it to make headlines pop smoke oh yeah
pop smoke I mean he was building a
pretty damn big following yeah yeah and
crazy [ __ ] is you hear this dude's voice
and he sounded like a [ __ ] 40 year
old man who smokes two packs of
cigarettes a day he's like 20. so
[ __ ] yeah he's a kid you know he's a
kid just out of his teens you know what
I mean and then he gets shot and killed
man how did he die he got shot I know
but uh in what context oh I don't know I
don't I don't know what the I mean he
was Affiliated so I'm pretty sure it's
something to do with that right and he
wasn't shy about claiming his hood so
yeah well the people person that we're
talking about that passed away which is
absolutely shocking because when we talk
about uh obviously us being Dusty and
old but everybody knows who the [ __ ]
Migos is right right funny [ __ ] about
Migos when they first came out onto the
scene I didn't know Migos was three
people
they all sound the same it's not even
they all look the same too so so the
first time I ever heard them was I or I
ever physically saw them was the Versace
video Versace Versace Versace Versace so
I thought that it was just the same guy
in three different outfits so I didn't
[ __ ] know the only reason why how I
found out that Migos was three separate
people yeah was from an episode in
Atlanta uh okay and my [ __ ] mind was
blown well it was thanks to Donald
Glover I mean Childish Gambino that they
got the shot I mean because they were
doing music well before you know he he
shouted them out when he was winning the
award but it was after that where like
overnight sensation everybody was on
that the bad and boujee remember yeah
and then they just have become kind of a
Mainstay in like pop culture and Hip-Hop
culture since then so Migos is like
it's interesting right because they
they're all related yeah yeah so that's
what basically we're talking about
takeoff was actually yeah it was offset
yeah cuevo take off an offset yeah yeah
and takeoff is the one that we're
talking about who passed away yeah right
who was shot yeah so their story is very
interesting because
you know when they first started coming
on right they were actually to I think
they're the rappers that made the uh I
don't know what they call like the
triplet the triplet wrap they made that
really popular right yeah but the the
well they call it the Mumble rap yeah
the Mumble rap yeah the triplet thing
Versace Versace Versace they were the
ones that kind of really made it pop off
and everybody bit their swag after and I
remember reading up about them a while
back and if you're a huge fan of the
Migos uh correct me if I'm wrong
but I heard two of them were actually
super into sports and it was actually
take off the one that passed away that
he was the one that was pursuing
pursuing music the hardest so uh the
other two relatives yeah they were like
either in I think they were in football
yeah but either way like music was kind
of their side thing and takeoff was the
one that was pursuing music so he was
performing as much as he can and he's
the one that took it seriously so he was
the reason why Migos actually popped off
because he believed in the music which
is ironic because it's arguable that
he's probably the least popular member
out of this interesting right yeah he
was the one that wasn't really talked
about a lot yeah because
um from what I've read online like in
terms of his personality he was that's
just his personality he's quiet he's not
very [ __ ] flashy and he's the one
that loves the music so he's kind of
like the heart of the Migos that people
don't really know about because he's the
one doing everything behind the scenes
which is kind of sad because he's the
one that's very subdued and he's the one
that passed away yeah so if you guys
don't know a lot about this because this
happened really recently obviously the
news is going to change a lot but just
from going online reading on Twitter
going on Reddit and reading a few
articles about this which is probably
the only reason why Reddit is good
like uh it happened at a bowling alley
out in Atlanta yeah and there was an
altercation between cuevo and whoever
else at the bowling alley on I forgot
which floor is like the third floor of
this bowling alley is a pretty popular
bowling alley out out in Atlanta and it
was like a group of [ __ ] 40 people
and apparently they were shooting dice
they were shooting dice or die or
whatever what the [ __ ] it is yeah and
something happened and the person who
actually what they're assuming based on
somebody's text thread that was there
apparently cuevo and uh take off
they don't ever just go in into a place
by themselves yeah like I'm not sure if
they're highly Affiliated or Atlanta
just watches their back yeah but it's
said or uh basically kind of proposed to
believe that takeoff was actually shot
by one of cuevos people because they
just started blasting oh and then he got
hit by a stray so while they were
[ __ ] shooting at the other people and
they were the first person to attack
yeah [ __ ] takeoff got hit yeah
accidentally wow yeah I didn't know that
it was possibly their own people yeah
that he got hit with the accidental
stray but yeah I mean because they just
started spraying and [ __ ] take off
got hit he was like the first person to
get hit yeah and apparently too they
were saying that uh other Witnesses were
saying that he was just chilling yeah he
was quiet he wasn't getting into the
altercation that cuevo was getting into
with the other person yeah and then
takeoff was just quiet as [ __ ] then
when she started popping off he stood up
and then he got shot dude wow did
anybody else get shots see that's what
I'm not familiar with uh there was a few
other people who got injured but nothing
uh fatal nothing fatal the cop was the
first person to get shot it was a fatal
wound wow yeah I mean look man you know
when um even if you rise to stardom and
Celebrity level if you kind of stay
affiliated with a certain group of
people like trouble's gonna come find
you you know it's like man if I if I
made Millions like that I don't know I'd
be chilling man you know you could
probably I don't know I'll build my own
bowling alley you know what I mean in my
house I think Eddie Murphy has his own
bowling alley in his own house that's
what I'm saying like you know I
understand that some of these you know
rappers or whatever uh coming from the
hood like they need people around them
to kind of like protect them but like
why are you putting yourself in that
environment in the first place you know
what I mean it's it's a weird thing
because like first of all I didn't know
that you could just shoot dice in a
bowling
well you can shoot it you can shoot dice
I mean you could slay anywhere you just
need a wall yeah you know like yeah
it's just like what they grew up with
you know what I mean like when you're
when you're out there playing in the
streets like like I said all you
literally need is a wall and it's a form
of gambling and entertainment for them
so and I know because my parents store
back in the day before the the area kind
of got cleaned up a little bit yeah and
you know I say cleaned up in terms of
I don't know if anybody disliked it
because I didn't dislike it so every and
I mentioned on the podcast before when I
was growing up at my parents store every
Thursday Friday and Saturday that was a
food truck named Moe's they would come
by and then everybody would have a block
party every Thursday Friday and Saturday
in front of my parents that's some
dedication to have a block party three
times a week bro every Thursday Friday
Saturday there was a block party and
[ __ ] music was bumping people would
come out yeah food truck Moe's Food
Truck was out there yeah and people will
be shooting dice literally in front of
my parents store they would get a piece
of cardboard they would bend it in half
and they would just be shooting dice in
front of my parents store yeah and they
were super nice to me so so you know it
wasn't for me it was cool so I would
just walk out I'd be seeing them shoot I
never learned how to play but I would
always watch and I would just go get
some tacos from [ __ ]
I would come back and eat what kind of
Roach Coach was it like was it a Mexican
Roach Coach or like no it was it was
everything was black owned okay so it
was just uh no I mean like the type of
food they were serving was it Mexican
food or was just whatever there's tacos
everything okay but he had these things
so nowadays like Gym Boys has franchised
out there's a gym Boys in SoCal now I
heard they're all over the place have
you ever been to a gym boys no so
Jimboy's is Hood food which is the
funniest thing so Gym Boys obviously
went through like a corporate Rebrand
because now they're franchising so you
see them all over the place yeah but Gym
Boys it was a it was like uh I wouldn't
know necessarily call it Tex-Mex but
they're basically a hood Taco spot okay
and they're hard tacos that are
basically griddled down with Parmesan
cheese so that parmesan cheese crust oh
they put the crust on there yeah okay so
it's greasy and crunchy as [ __ ] yeah
this was a hood ass spot only [ __ ]
people with no money would go there
because it was cheap that [ __ ] was fire
as [ __ ] yeah and so Moe's used to do his
version of that so I used to always get
those tacos or he would have like a
burrito and I used to always eat that
[ __ ] but they wish you'd dice there all
the time so like in my mind I'm thinking
at this bowling alley like who the [ __ ]
just brought in a piece of cardboard
people get stuck with their vices but
yeah this is the weird thing I know and
it's kind of interesting when I think
about the situation it's like I don't
know if I would stick to devices that I
don't know I don't even care if I enjoy
it once you reach a certain level of
notoriety and especially because like
you're in rap like hip-hop yeah hip-hop
is still like no matter how much we have
deviated from what it used to be because
you know it used to be like gangster rap
[ __ ] in the area that we grew up in
right and back in the day too like think
about it like this when we grew up you
didn't just get tattoos tattoos weren't
just [ __ ] that you [ __ ] had for art
like nobody looked at your tattoos for
art they would see that [ __ ] to see what
you're affiliated with yeah like
I said when I see people with tattoos
now it always blows my mind like oh I'm
gonna get a tattoo but back in the day
you didn't just get a [ __ ] tattoo you
got a tattoo either because you know you
got that little [ __ ] stamp or something
or if you were a dude it was like some
gang affiliation [ __ ] yeah or you got it
when you went inside you know yeah yeah
so it was like it you know I know things
have changed a lot but I feel like in
you know like what if somebody's already
like an Affiliated gang member I'm not
saying that they were or if they hang
around a certain crowd there's a lot of
dangers that come with it so to be able
just to walk around like that freely and
expect nothing to happen to you scares
me a little bit yeah I mean that's why
they have the security around them right
because
they're recognizable people know that
they got money so like you know if
they're traveling around doing tours or
whatever somebody might try to catch
them slipping right like what was it
with the xxxtentacion yeah they were
basic they ran up on him right he was in
in his like Lambo right he was the dude
who got he got shot yeah yeah I shot
this car in the car right yeah so it's
like you know what I mean it's I don't
think the dude was out looking for
trouble or anything it just happened
yeah it just happened because I I don't
know maybe somebody I for because I
forget I vaguely remember what the story
was behind like the dudes who who shot
and killed him I don't know if they were
people that uh he had beef with or they
were just trying to rob him what the
situation was but I'm saying it's like
you can get it anywhere right and so I
understand the the need for people with
guns around you I mean hopefully it's
it's like security people who have the
license and and like they can legally
carry but yeah once it becomes kind of
more of a hood thing like you just hire
in your homies who's strapped up like
this [ __ ]
they're not trained professionals and it
can get out of hand really quickly in
that sense right whereas you know
um a trained security guard who might be
even ex-military right they know how to
assess the situation and kind of read
the room and look for any potential
threats or yeah but you just got a dude
your homie with a gun yeah what a gun
just start spraying yeah it's like ship
as soon as [ __ ] pops off it's like yeah
you bust it out and you start capping
like he literally killed the person he
was supposed to protect that's crazy
that's crazy yeah there was a nurse who
was uh who was there too I guess she
lived in the neighborhood and she heard
the gun there's always a nurse
yeah there's always a nurse on the scene
trying to help somebody so the nurse uh
she was kind of account uh she wrote
like a witness account of what happened
and she said she heard something pop off
and you know her being a nurse hear
people screaming or somebody screaming
and the person that was screaming was
actually cuevo so quavo was screaming
and then she runs down and she realized
it was the Migos and she sees uh take
off and she goes by the time I already
got there he was dead like his eyes
already rolled back his head was up yes
he already passed yeah but the funny
thing is like when she was there was
comments that were writing and she was
like defending herself people were like
why didn't you give him the CPR it's
like first of all
you [ __ ] dummy are you a medical
[ __ ] professional the [ __ ]
audacity yeah because and she was
explaining too it's like in that
situation you do not give CPR like
people watch TV and they go listen I
know what to do yeah like this is the
most resuscitate him his neck is chopped
up no we can we can bring him back why
don't you reattach his head yeah you're
[ __ ] useless just give him CPR it's
all good so I'm reading some of these
comments like there's no way and there
was people like oh this nurse is useless
she should at least try to administer
CPR on him so she could have saved them
like
are you [ __ ] dumb yeah are you the r
word yeah
[ __ ] like are you that [ __ ]
stupid yeah the the audacity like this
woman who actually went on scene to go
ahead and try to save this person assess
the situation saw that he had no color
in his face his eyes were rolled back
yeah and his neck was up which basically
and she checked this pulse it was done
they're like give him CPR you could have
saved them it's like [ __ ] the internet
is [ __ ] funny yeah I mean everybody
everybody uh are professionals you know
they're they're Professionals in every
field because they can do a quick Google
search and without fact checking
anything a buddy of mine who's a doctor
who was telling me this funny ass story
I was talking to him on the phone and
this was about a month ago but he was
out in New York and uh when he was out
in New York he was at a club and one of
the things that a lot of doctors
apparently don't like doing is letting
people know that they're doctors because
immediately everybody looks to them to
do some [ __ ] right and it's not because
that they're
uh they don't want to work or help
people out is because they can't help
everybody in these situations exactly
exactly and they'll be liable for things
right so they don't you know oh you're a
doctor I've been having this crazy [ __ ]
on my dick can you take a quick look at
it while you're here I'm just getting
coffee my man bro so this fool he's at a
club right yeah he goes to a club with
uh with one of our mutual friends and
what are mutual friends is a little
[ __ ] dummy you know so somebody at
the club apparently like in a booth
starts having like a seizure oh it
should it collapses yeah and so my buddy
stuff yeah he's a funny ass guy he's
just like has not heard about this year
I was like I don't hope nobody finds out
I'm a doctor
she's I'm just trying to get my club on
right now guess what our mutual friend
does he's a doctor he can help and he
looks at him like you [ __ ] out of
your mind so he goes okay let me go see
and assess the situation so he walks
over to this person at the club yeah
this person is you know convulsing or
whatever he's on the floor he's like
okay let me see what happens and of
course because the person who's a doctor
who actually has like medical knowledge
should be helping this person out other
guy comes in not a medical professional
at all
comes up he grabs the guy's leg who's on
the floor he's passed out lifts it up
and he goes what are you doing he goes
I'm trying to help he goes
stop yeah don't [ __ ] lift his legs
and move out the way he goes she's
trying to help he goes
you [ __ ] doing you asked you guys are
asking me to come over don't touch him
yeah and so he's assessing the situation
he looks at his friends and he goes so
uh what drugs were you guys doing he
goes we don't do drugs and he just he
said he looked at him he rolled his eyes
he goes all right yeah he goes you know
either way we're gonna find out right
right what drugs was he doing and
they're like no we don't we're not doing
any drugs he goes all right then he's
dead yeah what did you do here I'm out
of here he's like so [ __ ] irritated
right now he goes so I'm here to help
you have one guy who's administering
like whatever CPR shaking his legs
and he's not mad at him because he told
him to stop doing that because he's
making the situation worse he's trying
to figure out what's wrong with it so he
could tell the EMTs what's happening and
they won't tell him oh my God I'm not a
[ __ ] cop just tell me what drugs he's
taking so we can figure out what to do
next he finally told him but he's like
this is why I hate doing this [ __ ]
because it's so so annoying everybody's
an expert well that and you know it's um
the liability aspect of it right like
you mentioned I I don't know what kind
of possible legal trouble you might get
into like because just because I don't
know how it works with doctors it's like
are they able to because it's like an
off-duty doctor the same thing as like
an off duty copy yeah I don't know I
don't know either I should have asked
yeah I don't know how that works but you
know either way it's it's just hilarious
that they ask they find out he's a
doctor ask them to come over to help and
then the guy tries to do some crazy [ __ ]
like lift his legs up yeah I'm just
trying to help my man I didn't ask you
to do that she's like stop touch oh I
think too he told me like one of the
guys were like grabbing and dragging him
they're like stop touching him man he
was like getting so pissed yeah it's
just the worst situation ever and you
know the crazy thing about the cuevo
situation is like an offset or takeoff
situation well yeah apparently cuevo it
was an altercation that quavo started
yeah that got offset killed right like
he has to live with that for the rest of
his life that's his nephew you know his
[ __ ] nephew yeah
um but again man it's just one of those
things where it's like I feel like
because I don't think anybody expects to
get killed at a bowling alley but then
you also have to kind of assess like
okay what part of the hood is the
bowling alley in and what kind of people
are gonna be there like you know what I
mean I I feel like you gotta use better
judgment especially when you have that
kind of
um
visibility and and like wealth and yeah
but you know you can't fault them for
going out to have a good time it's just
that
yeah I don't know man you you gotta you
gotta use better judge because like even
even with the whole Korea situation like
right all the all the deaths that happen
and we gotta talk about that I forgot
about that [ __ ] yeah an Ito one right
hundreds of or hun was it like almost
150 people died you know uh Cardiac
Arrest got crushed to death when I
looked at that I was like you know
that's sad that that many people lost
their lives but what a [ __ ] shame
that they lost their lives like that
yeah you know what I mean like the need
to party was greater than using comments
like bro cause there was a ton of
footage that came out from that whole
thing right
people shooting videos from like
hundreds of feet away you could see what
that [ __ ] Street looked like if I saw
that I wouldn't go in nope nope a lot
and you know here's a here's a crazy
[ __ ] A lot of people ended up just going
home even from the uh the Subway because
the subway was getting so packed uh into
italon they were just like you know what
[ __ ] this is this like too crazy so if
you guys don't know where it is one's
like a popping spot yeah it's popping a
lot of young people go there a lot of
foreigners a lot of [ __ ] foreigners
yeah so this Halloween thing has been
happening for a while but because of
kovid uh it just hasn't been around it's
the first year it's been back yeah the
first year since covet started so people
were like super hyped and it's a place
that gets busy but it got especially
busy because people just like oh yeah
we're finally having a Halloween party
again you know yeah but it's just it's
one of those things again where it's
just like looking at the situation it
could have been easily avoided for those
people you know because like the moment
you get close to it and it's like your
shoulder just shrinks in like that bro
I'm out of here man it like I'm not
[ __ ] going down that street but
oh my God the [ __ ] like these people
were wedged and so tight that when
um responders came onto the scene
couldn't even get to them they no they
were trying to literally pull them out
they couldn't because they were wedged
and so tight so you see people at an
angle like basically wedged in and
that's the position that they're sitting
in or standing in I guess and who knows
if their feet is touching the ground or
not or they're elevated right and the
responders are literally trying to pull
them grab them by the arms and pull
they're not even budging that's how
tightly jam-packed and wedged they're in
and then so like imagine you know some
of the shorter people right like the
shorter girls shorter guys they're just
gonna disappear and into the [ __ ] sea
of people and people won't even know
that they're stomping them to death or
you know they're suffocating them just
because they disappear what a stupid
[ __ ] way to die that's like imagine
that morning you being a parent and you
[ __ ] getting a call saying your child
died last night and you say what the
[ __ ] happened
they got crushed to death in an Alleyway
because there's too many people
like it's again it's sad but I'm like
what a [ __ ] waste of life man
the thing I can't wrap my head around is
like
is there like a sale going on at least
like in Walmart there's a TV that's a
hundred dollars it's a 4K TV that's 55
inches that's a hundred dollars and
people gotta get it I'm not I'm not
saying yeah but it's a smart idea for
you to trample people to get that TV
yeah yeah but I'm saying yeah that's 100
TV right right
at this point yeah so I was also reading
um
I could I could read Korean so I was
like reading like other like you know
create accounts and they were saying
that there were people that were saying
don't go in there don't go like go back
home people are dying yeah and people
still went in yeah they still went in
they were like people die and they're
like oh I don't care
I'm coming in yeah
here people talk [ __ ] about America
anymore
everybody's dumb yeah I mean the the
thing is like the Walmart example you
brought up and and kind of like how it
uh mirrors against this situation in
Korea there definitely was negligence in
terms of like the planning of of this
type of [ __ ] happening like because the
city should have planned for that right
and they should have people yeah they
should have had safety measures in place
to make sure that type of [ __ ] does not
happen like that a crowd Crush does not
happen just like in the Walmart
situation they should have had a plan in
place to make sure that these people are
coming in an orderly fashion not just a
hey you guys need to stand 100 yards
away and when we say go everybody just
run it's like they were doing it for
their own self entertainment how did you
even have fun when you can't move that's
what I'm saying I guess like logically
for me like once again
I'm not sitting here making fun of
anybody who passed away this is not me
making jokes I'm trying to understand
how are you having fun when you can't
move or see or do anything or or even
even before you get to that why would
you like willingly go into that that's
the part that blows my mind like
claustrophobic or not if I see that and
it's a straight up no I'm like nah
whatever is going on in that Alleyway is
not worth me trying to [ __ ] go
through that this could also be too just
like people living on the internet and
not knowing anything yeah they just
don't know anything at all like
in general too just for me on a def on a
defensive position alone I'm not trying
to go anywhere where people are touching
me like that because I could get stabbed
up people could swipe my [ __ ] right and
people are just like no [ __ ] it it's
okay yeah no no no no no no like I don't
understand the [ __ ] logic behind this
you did not have to lose your life if
I'm saying like my mom was actually
calling me about it too because she was
like I feel so sad because imagine like
if you when you were 18 and she goes
well I don't think you would have ever
gone to stuff like that I was like no
you're 100 right I wouldn't have yeah
she goes but you know waking up one day
and you're trying to call your kid or
your kid's not coming home and you found
out that they died from going to a party
yeah they and some people weren't even
found for like a few days yeah because
it was just people literally piled on
top of each other who was the who was it
was it Travis Travis Barker the the
concert that's Travis Scott
Travis Barker is the blink-182.
I said Travis Barker
but Travis Scott had his concert and it
was the same situation it was the exact
same thing there was a witness account
somebody who survived this situation
where they said that um when they were
uh either crowd surfing or whatever they
fell through and they were having a good
time and they didn't realize when they
looked down and they were pressing
against the floor yeah that they yeah
they were stepping on people like two
layers of people yeah and like this girl
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah she didn't
know that she was stepping on Pierre uh
and then you know that's how some people
died yeah and you know whenever you read
or hear about like the account of what
that sensation is like it's crazy
because people just say that you are
moving without any like uh it's like an
ocean way right any power of your own
you just go wherever the the momentum is
going and that's scary man like for you
to not be able to physically do anything
and you just like moving along with
whatever you know shift is happening and
again some people's feet aren't even
touch in the ground yeah you know like
that's and then it just gets Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter until yeah you
[ __ ] get crushed to death you have
Cardiac Arrest or you know like like I
don't understand that [ __ ] I just I
still don't understand how when people
saw that crowd where nobody is moving
yeah and they were like oh let me just
go into yeah I don't get it that's the
part that blows my mind too like that
that that's the disconnect for me it's
just again like
when you see that
why would you willingly decide to be
like yeah that seems fine yeah or matter
of fact maybe they're not even thinking
but like why doesn't it stop you to at
least assess the situation like ah do I
really want to go into that that crowd
that should look super [ __ ] tight you
know
um and the crazy [ __ ] was is like man
there are people partying right across
the street literally don't even know
what the [ __ ] is going on which is that
that hundreds of people have died like
their [ __ ] music is still blasting
they're [ __ ] chanting you know sex on
the beach like
yet literally right across the street
this [ __ ] Mayhem is happening you
know it it's just it was just a
disastrous situation all around and
again it's like not to take anything
away from the people
um who lost their lives and the family
members or like you know the P the
friends and uh family that knew them but
it's just yeah when I look at it it's
like again I it's sad but I'm just like
why man why the [ __ ] did you put
yourself in that situation you know I
don't know man I got I'm already
claustrophobic as it is and the only
reason why I like howling growing up was
because of the uh scantly
walking about it's like it was the best
it's just the candy for me man I love
candy so
I'm a different candidate
and she was fantastic man I'm like what
are these flusies yeah no I mean that
was good when we were like in college
right like what the Halloween parties
where where all the girls are dressed up
you know I love it because it was funny
too because there would be like certain
home girls too who never ever dressed
like that but they would only do it for
Halloween I know I'm like dude when did
you get those titties I had no [ __ ]
idea they've been hiding them man I know
you're usually a scrub yeah what is this
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it was the best time
of the year dude it was better than
Christmas
I shouldn't say dress up I should say
dress down
the floozies in Halloween were fan
[ __ ] tastic man yeah did you pass out
any oh wait you didn't pass out any
candy no because I live in an apartment
complex so oh yeah so I live in a
neighborhood that is uh super uh White
you know there's there's no [ __ ] die
shooting happening here yeah so I got I
was before we moved in here so last year
I moved into another very white
neighborhood and I got hyped right so
growing up as a kid
I just remember the homes I wanted to be
the person that was an adult that would
give out the best candy yeah like the
full-size candy bars and [ __ ] like that
so but because I know like you know kids
can't even be eating full-size
Butterfingers anyways yeah so I just got
a couple of variety packs of stuff but
they didn't get one I gave them five
pieces of candy yes they got four
different kinds of candy and they got a
Rice Krispie Treat too that's such a
legit such a legit uh giveaway hell yeah
so like these kids they saw what they
got they're like oh wow this is awesome
like [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] so I was
giving out this candy I was super hyped
right
uh it turns out you know what we we made
a total of 80 80 bags it wasn't enough
damn like the neighborhood I live in has
all children yeah so they were coming in
[ __ ] droves yeah dog one of the
things that I hate it's like my biggest
pet peeve is when a [ __ ] adult comes
to my house
that [ __ ] pisses me off like none other
but are they in costume or are they just
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't listen to me
if you if you're above the age of 20 and
you come on my doorstep I'm passing out
hands
I'm listening
are you out of your [ __ ] mind so I
was outside and I was like
out in the front and people were already
starting to trick or treat it was a
little early I saw this grown ass man by
the way this is not adults or like their
older brothers or sisters that are
coming with like their younger siblings
yeah I'm talking about a group of like
four like 18 19 20 year olds and I see
these [ __ ] walking up to my
house yeah and these guys I [ __ ] you
[ __ ] not yeah I look at them they're
like
first of all you got a giant voice
there's no [ __ ] way this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I'm like no yeah like are you
here to get candy he goes yeah can I
have some candy I'm like no I I
literally told him no I was like these
for the [ __ ] kids bro yeah I
was like did you come here in a car yeah
I was like you were getting [ __ ]
candy though if you could afford gas in
your car you gotta get twinkle tweet hey
you know what though last time I went
trick-or-treating I think I was 19.
that was like
um kind of a one-off type of thing where
it was something like my ex at the time
and we were some friends and then we're
just like on Halloween night we're like
hey you know what do you want to do and
then we didn't have any plans so it was
just like hey you guys want to just
[ __ ] trick or treat for old time's
sake like just go for like an hour or
two say something I would have shot you
on site so we yeah we did it for like an
hour or two
um I mean we didn't get a lot of cat it
was just more for like Nostalgia
purposes you know if I see a group of
four adults come to my house ask me for
candy dude I would [ __ ] in your bag
this full these fools I was like bro are
you seriously gonna try to take candy
from these kids yeah because imagine if
I gave the candy to these guys the the
four kids without candy yeah absolutely
not and then we want and then you know
it's funny I was talking to neighbors
they're like did you see those [ __ ]
adults like trying to get I was like
yeah who the [ __ ] are they they weren't
even a part of the neighborhood they
were just going around trying to get
candy I'm like these are haters bro
like I said I was about to pass out some
[ __ ] ass whoopings that night dog I
remember specifically uh one of the
um adults when I went that time was like
because I I wasn't in costume I was just
wearing street clothes like yeah what
are you supposed to be I was like broke
college student and they're laughing
like fair enough I mean it was true I'm
not lying you know I'm not doing none of
that [ __ ] dude like even like when I was
in high school like I remember like a
couple of my high school friends like 14
15 they're like we're gonna go
trick-or-treating I'm like y'all a bunch
of [ __ ] losers by [ __ ] going on at
that age there wasn't even like a
consideration it wasn't even brought up
but like yeah you know it was just like
just something completely random it was
like it started off as a joke like
should we go trick-or-treating it's like
yeah [ __ ] it why not you know let's do
it for old time's sake
honestly it like it was it brought back
like good memories for because you know
we didn't overstay our welcome with that
memory and it's just like an hour or so
so this is time at my parents house
[ __ ] first of all we would have
never the house that would pass out
candy right number one I was poor I
couldn't afford [ __ ] the either ones who
would turn off the lights number one I
just didn't have we were broke no
[ __ ] [ __ ] like buying candy for us
was not an option we could barely afford
food yeah so buying candy for other
people was like we don't got this
because also my parents were you know
donating you know they're helping out
the church and [ __ ] too so that's where
all of our money went but uh [ __ ]
these kids and with them kids they were
like I don't know I would say junior
high and the other one like a few of
them were in high school or whatever
and I how old was I I think I was like a
senior so they weren't even number one
they weren't going to my high school so
I don't know who the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] were and told them I'm
sorry we don't have any candy yeah and
so as I'm walking out they leave and my
mom was asking me to throw away the
garbage she's like cool I was about to
throw in the garbage I see this fool
with an egg in his head my house yeah I
beat the [ __ ] out of this dude and his
friend yeah it was like two people like
two two guys just watched a bunch of
[ __ ] I got so [ __ ] mad this guy's
blind too yeah picking this egg and I'm
literally watching this [ __ ]
Chuck's the egg at my house I'm in the
front yeah
I'm right there yeah
[ __ ] pissed me off because I was
super cool is like hey bro I'm sorry we
don't have any candy man but they're all
cool whatever they walk by this guy's
about to egg my [ __ ] house yeah I
beat the living [ __ ] [ __ ] out of this
dude that was the thing though that was
the thing uh when we were younger
growing up is that like you know
people's eggs got or houses got egged
when yeah or teepeed when they didn't
give out candy but yeah you know when
you're young kids you're not thinking
about oh you know maybe they're not in
the best financials you're just like oh
what a [ __ ] party pooper y'all whack
as [ __ ] you know I don't give up
right there too well if I go old enough
too you're like a sophomore or some [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] mother [ __ ] yeah if if I
saw somebody egg in my house at that age
and I'm standing there while they do it
yeah shit's going down for sure [ __ ] was
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah it's weird now
too just because of uh how how I think
and what I do now like even to go back
to talk about like the whole Migo
situation like you know how how you were
saying too like some people have like
old habits that die hard because they're
so used to living a certain lifestyle
I'll go back home like see the place
that I used to kick it at and I'm
looking at these [ __ ] like
chilling outside the liquor store I'm
like you [ __ ] vagabonds
you pieces of [ __ ] and I was one of them
yeah but I look at them and I get scared
right look at these [ __ ] like I
can't go back to doing [ __ ] like that no
for sure for sure and that's what I'm
saying is just like using common sense
and just being kind of practical about
the situation and assessing the
situation be like ah you know what nah
you know whatever it is that I need to
go there for it's not worth it it's
worth it all worth it especially when
like you could always tell too when
somebody's about to start [ __ ] like
you're walking in and they just [ __ ]
mean mug you you're staring I'm like
this is not worth it I'm just gonna go
somewhere else yeah I mean you know it's
nice actually not getting me mugged
anymore maybe because I'm in age now
where like yeah I am almost a
middle-aged dude so
um it's it's a nice change of Pace to be
like walking around in places and not
getting Mean Mug because that was
happening like well into my college
Years you know that I was still getting
mean mugged like when I'm at certain
places I'm just like
man come on I'm just trying to live a
[ __ ] normal life man I'm not I don't
I don't want any trouble but I don't
know man I guess when you look a certain
way or you're of a certain age
because let's let's be honest even for
us around College time things are still
a little you know yeah yeah yeah it
wasn't it wasn't nowhere near what it is
today yeah yeah for sure for sure yeah
you still have to kind of be careful
when you when you're going out right now
it's a lot more peaceful and people in
general seem to be a little more
friendlier but back then there was a
good amount of unfriendly people that
you had to you had to kind of look out
for
um and yeah just like being in front of
a 7-Eleven [ __ ] drinking a Gatorade
after playing basketball for a few hours
bug that I [ __ ] AMPM when I was a kid
dude it's just [ __ ] those are because
those were some of the worst spots to be
at late at night yeah because that's
where all this was in broad daylight
okay that's pretty bad in the store in
front of the [ __ ] worker the worker
didn't do she didn't do [ __ ]
this guy literally socked me in my nose
and then took my money in the store yep
he didn't say nothing to you you just
walked up to me he was like empty your
pocket so I'm like
oh
I'm hella young yeah I don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening yeah yeah they
call it like whatever whatever not the
bystander effect but it's like when you
normalize these weird situations you
don't know how to react because it's not
in your normal reality right right
and the Abacus I was like huh in my
[ __ ] nose and they took my [ __ ] and I
was crying right there and the [ __ ]
guy just watched the whole thing go down
I'm not even call the cops no wow I
think you were scared too wow but that
guy too he was in my high school oh he
was like saying around same age as you I
was a freshman he was a senior wow yeah
and he was uh so he was just basically
punking you yep yeah he was uh the one
white dude in a group of all black kids
yeah and it always had cornrows yeah all
the time this [ __ ] loser
beat up a little kid who just got in the
[ __ ] high school I was like what so I
was like 13. yeah he's like probably 26
because he failed multiple times 26 year
old high school student why did he do it
at a gas station why did he hit you up
at a gas station dog I should you
[ __ ] not random [ __ ] I'm literally
there I'm getting a drink I turn around
and do your pockets huh but socks to be
my [ __ ] nose and then he just takes
my [ __ ] and then he walks out oh wow
that's it he wasn't even laughing
nothing he just took it like it was his
he almost took my money as a if I stole
his money first yeah
I never heard that kind of [ __ ]
happening at a you know broad daylight I
had a [ __ ] AMPM dude I would never
people have asked me this question too
or they you know I think people in
general ask this question they go if you
had a time machine and you could go back
in time would you do it I'm like nope
lovely genius farts this podcast is
brought to you by betterhelp online
therapy my friends I have been using
better help for quite a while now you
guys already know I'm all about focusing
on your mental health as much as my
physical health because I can't work on
my physical stuff unless I'm working on
my mental and I will keep on saying that
because when I decide to focus on my
mental health I became a better person
inside and out there are times where I
felt like I couldn't talk to anybody and
that's where me finding the right
therapist that matched me really really
helped out navigating any of life's
challenges can make you feel unsure
whether it's a career change a new
relationship or even becoming a parent
so therapists are trained to help you to
figure out what the cause of challenging
emotions and it helps you learn
productive coping skills as the world's
largest therapy service better help has
match three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online and plus
more importantly it's affordable just
fill out a brief questionnaire to match
with the therapist if things aren't
clicking you could easily switch to a
new therapist and they any time and it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's better help
help.com genius
my life would not me I
I mean you know I went through a lot of
hardships growing up uh since since like
you know I was I was a young kid but
I feel like I don't take those
situations for granted in terms of like
what it instilled in me and what it
taught like don't get me wrong I mean if
I could remove a lot of the [ __ ]
traumatic events and and you know I
would but at the same time like we
turned out okay you know what I mean I
mean we we could have had an easier life
but
I I don't regret what I am right now you
know what I mean 100 I just don't want
to go back and experience all that [ __ ]
that's true
that's true
Doug if you guys don't remember when I
first started YouTube I was like legally
blind I had these thick ass bifocals
when I would wake up in the morning yeah
somebody could just [ __ ] me in my ass
and I wouldn't even know who was doing
me right now what what was your
prescription negative 10 negative 11.
wow I was legally blind that's like
double what I am like if I woke up and
somebody flipped me over and started
[ __ ] me in the ass I would just think
it was a ghost holy [ __ ]
what is happening I didn't know your
eyes were that bad though my eyes were
bad like it would be an inch away from
my face I could see something yeah yeah
so whatever like when I would grow up
then I would get punked like let's say I
don't know at school you would get into
a fight if my glasses were off I was
just swinging
so I was probably hitting women
the crazy [ __ ] is Charles Oliveira
fought like that before his Lasik yeah
he said he sees three people in the cage
and he has to pick one person to fight
yeah no and he goes for the one in the
middle that's so [ __ ] funny but it's
like after his last fight it's like bro
can you undo whatever it was that you
got done for your your vision correction
God
[ __ ] uh
like my vision was so bad it looked like
from what I remember
if you have ever had sunglasses and
somebody smeared grease on it yeah
that's what it looks like oh no I
couldn't see [ __ ] so there would be
times that I wouldn't go to school yeah
because I would fall asleep with my
glasses on and I couldn't find my
glasses that's amazing and then my
parents yeah they would go to work yeah
so they weren't there to help me out so
I would wake up and then I can't see
where my [ __ ] glasses are yeah so for
like an hour and a half to two hours I'm
looking for these glasses blind because
I can't see anything dude I can't even
because like I'm I'm minus six so like I
can't even imagine what minus 10 minus
11 is like I would pray for minus six
yeah like minus six is perfect dude no I
mean because like even with minus six
without my contacts or glasses bro I
can't drive I can't [ __ ] go out and
if you can see like something here right
no I can't see that it needs to be like
here yeah it needs to be here for me to
be able to see oh for me yeah it had to
be yeah it was like right in like so I
used to do this thing where I wanted to
see how bad my my vision was getting
yeah so I remember when I first started
testing it out I would measure my hand
distance from the wall to my nose so it
would be like this if you guys were
watching this on video it's like me
doing like a Shaka sign and like this
and I remember what it just started
getting closer and closer and closer to
the point where basically my pinky and
thumbs were touching and I'm like okay
now it's this and it got to this point
dude I didn't even realize I had bad
eyes until like middle of high school
like people always thought I was angry
and dogging people because I was
squinting did I just couldn't see [ __ ] I
just couldn't see [ __ ] you know he's so
bad Bros
and like I'm just trying to [ __ ] look
bro you know and then um there was like
uh a mandated like vision test or
whatever a physical thing at at school
and that's when I found out that I
needed glasses and like your eyes are
bad I don't even know you wore glasses
I've never seen you wear glasses yeah so
I only wear glasses um at the end of the
night when I'm like all washed up take
out my contacts but then I don't like
wearing glasses out because it's not
comfortable for me yeah so I almost
wearing contacts instead but I need to
get Lasik it's like I mean you should
yeah I I just kept putting it off I
don't know why I've had it now for 10
years and my vision isn't 2020 anymore
yeah but it's still it's a little under
yeah but it's still really really
[ __ ] good I'm actually my eye doctor
was surprised like how well my my uh
operations stood up like usually by the
time after 10 years yeah it's like
integrated right the grades a lot but
your vision's still pretty good that's
crazy yeah so like my vision like it's
oh it always sucked because I used to
play basketball so I didn't want to wear
the goggles so my glass would always fly
off so my lips were scraped I know all
the [ __ ] time yeah and like just
being blind I can never go back to that
[ __ ] like I remember when I first got uh
so I got this other thing it wasn't
called Lasik it's called like ICL
surgery so they have a permanent contact
in your eye oh okay it's essentially
what people get when they have a
glaucoma yeah okay okay and so I get
this surgery and I remember I wake up
and then I I could see and so when you
have like really poor vision or if you
have glasses your peripherals are really
narrow yeah and so I wrote my preference
with this [ __ ] life yeah and it was
the craziest thing ever but whenever my
eyes were dry your vision kind of blurs
with Lasik yeah so instead of putting
eye drops I would keep touching my nose
to to raise my glasses or fix my glasses
that I don't have on my face because it
became so habitual at that so I would
just keep doing this yeah and the other
day I was wearing a glasses just as a
joke to see what it looks like and I'm
like I can't even imagine my face with
glasses now because I haven't had
glasses right so which is so funny
because like when you first started out
that was like one of your looks it was
the thing yeah yeah when I didn't have
glasses people hated it yeah they're
like dude I missed you with glasses that
was my look yeah right your your thick
black frame glasses yeah like the thick
black and I only had thick black frames
because the lenses were so thick
yeah they try to mask it somehow dog my
life was miserable bro I couldn't see
for [ __ ] yeah now I can't even imagine
wearing glasses now like I don't know
what that's gonna look like or even feel
like yeah no I I I would love to be able
to wake up in the morning and just have
Clear Vision you know okay it's like
yeah it's kind of frustrating
um when you don't have the glasses or
contacts in because like even when I'm
on a trip or something and then like you
know I have to pop out my contacts and
sometimes I'll forget my glasses and I'm
like oh [ __ ] now it's gonna be a bit of
an ordeal like getting around like
because it's a area they're surrounding
you're not familiar with you know
um but yeah just to have like 2020 or
damn near 2020 Vision without anything
yeah it would be a big like Improvement
in quality of life so this is the
funniest thing so I I was there when
Mario first got Lasik right so she had
similar Vision to mine like negative oh
[ __ ] damn you're blind too yeah and so
yeah when we have kids our kids gonna be
blind so this girl's so [ __ ] dramatic
so she gets her Lasik right yeah
and the Lasik operations honestly about
20 minutes right it's very fast you
don't even go to sleep well yeah you
have to be awake because yeah you you
have to you know so because your eyes
can't roll back yeah so she's getting
the operation I'm there she go
this girl comes out
and I see her walk out and this is what
she says she goes
I can find at least
yeah
dude you're not supposed to cry no
afterwards oh you can't okay fine
because it's like it's like eye drops oh
okay okay I can't find I was like [ __ ]
you weren't blind you could always see
you just can see without contact
[ __ ] nonsense I can finally see you
should be like bawling I'm like dude
this is the most anticlimactic [ __ ]
she's happy man she's happy that you
know she comes she's finally free
because bro that [ __ ] it adds up and
it's you know like when I have the
contacts and the [ __ ] gets dry or like
it gets like it gets into a weird part
of your eye and you're trying to like
adjust it to like get get it placed back
correctly you know to not have to deal
with that I mean either way yeah you're
gonna have to deal with that in a sense
because you're you have to use a lot of
eye drops like that doesn't end like for
the rest of your life your eyes will be
dry okay so you'll be putting in eye
drops like four or five times a day wow
yeah but you're gonna need it yeah if
you don't then your vision gets bad
because you're just [ __ ] it up I see
but it's not a problem like I put eye
drops right when I wake up before I go
to sleep and then like a couple times
throughout the day we're talking about
like re-wet drops just like those they
have ones for like people who
specifically get Lasik oh I see um okay
but better the eye drops it just feels
good yeah like you're gonna hate it
that's why when I whenever I go to Vegas
yeah
terrible because dry so dry Ryan
have you seen like Barton Geo always
like posting the like I can't believe
how lovely it is in Vegas shut the [ __ ]
up you two [ __ ] losers dude you live
in a [ __ ] desert
I always give him [ __ ] he's always post
on his [ __ ] story she goes I can't
believe I get to live here I was like no
I can't believe you lived there
what do you mean like I had this
beautiful home I was like it's in a
desert yeah it's like that's why bro but
hey [ __ ] it's hard to blame a man with
the cost of living here in La man it's
tough man yeah it is I love the weather
out here I love the [ __ ] beaches I
love the food I love the culture I love
all that [ __ ] yeah but something about
sometimes California be pissing me off
man yeah and California in their [ __ ]
criminal [ __ ] California and their taxes
and you know what you know I don't ever
talk about politics I'm not very
political but I'm not even considered a
liberal anymore like I thought I was
liberal I'm not people think I'm
conservative but like the definition and
the skew of being being liberal and
conservative is here and here now oh
yeah it's here and here well even
moderate even moderate has moved over to
the right you know
um
most of the times now people who Define
themselves as moderate is because they
don't want to deal with I think the
stigma that comes with being called or
calling yourself a conservative these
days or a liberal yeah
um but whatever the case is yeah it's
it's definitely got pushed to the
extremes
um and you can't even say you don't care
anymore if you don't care that means
you're complicit if you're complicit
you're a piece of [ __ ] how about you
just leave me the [ __ ] alone yeah let's
start with that [ __ ] like I like that's
the thing I've heard I or I see
constantly online they're like oh you
don't care well why are you a [ __ ]
American hey I don't know how come my
nuts aren't in your mouth dude how about
that [ __ ] let's start with that yeah
how about it's okay for people to say I
don't know it is now the rhetoric where
you can't say I don't know even though I
don't know is sometimes the most honest
thing you can say yeah I mean I I
personally have haven't seen you know
like attacks from from stuff like that
but at the same time it doesn't surprise
me just kind of the the landscape of
like
left first right and and everything in
between it's just gotten so out of
control and it's
there's a lot of hate man there's a lot
of [ __ ] hate with what's going on I
mean you know after Paul Pelosi Nancy
Pelosi's husband got attacked it's like
politics aside he got physically
attacked dude you got their house got
broken into and he got hammered to the
Head
oh I didn't hear about this when did
this happen this was like a week ago
what the [ __ ] yeah dude and that and no
way the person who broke into the home
was looking for Nancy Pelosi but she was
uh away on the tour doing stuff for work
but Paul Pelosi your husband was there
this guy's an 80 year old man he's
[ __ ] like so fortunate he survived
this [ __ ] he survived he survived he got
surgery he was in the hospital for a
while and yeah he he's gonna make a full
recovery apparently but he took a camera
to the head man do you have any idea
what kind of psychopath will Hammer
somebody what I'm saying that is a a
visceral and disgusting way to try to
kill someone but but here's the [ __ ] I
mean like obviously this dude's a
mentally Disturbed person right and you
know people
um looked into the background this guy
and you know he's what you think he
would be the reason why he would attack
a Pelosi right he believes in all the
conspiracy theories that you know Trump
should still be president the vote was
stolen all this crazy [ __ ] right he
believes in that he buys into it and he
went there because he felt like Nancy
Pelosi has to pay for being what she is
you know
um but here's the crazy [ __ ] for me is
that like okay politics aside everything
aside we can objectively say that is a
heinous act nobody should be on the
receiving end of that and nobody should
be doing that for any reason whatsoever
the freaking right
we're having a field day with this
making jokes really yeah they were like
politicians politicians were making
jokes out of this and they're and then
another conspiracy theory spawned from
that that it was actually Paul Pelosi's
uh gay Playboy that he was having fun
with and then things just went South
it's wild bro it's like how do you as a
person who's an actual politician not
even just somebody talking politics an
actual politic how can you [ __ ] make
light of a situation like this
regardless of whether they're on the
opposing end of whatever you believe in
it's like dude just as a human being
like that shouldn't have happened no
matter what but that's what I'm saying
it's so far off the [ __ ] rails now
that they're making fun of and making
light of a situation like that and it's
just crazy to me like I like I don't
give a [ __ ] if you're left to right like
a human being yeah just as as a human
being getting attacked in a in a vicious
and brutal way like with a hammer nobody
deserves that right I know
ah Putin Maybe
let me backtrack here because they no
but
Paul Pelosi definitely didn't deserve
that
um and it it wasn't a situation that was
how do you break into their home so
that's the big mystery right because it
shouldn't they have like security that's
what I'm saying right like you got these
people who are not only like multi
multi-millionaires but they're public
figures they live in a private Community
like how the [ __ ] did this guy those
bodyguards are there too
know how to do [ __ ] yeah so I I I'm not
really sure um how they got how he got
into it
um like he broke glass to get in and
then like some of the conspiracy theory
that came is like but the glass
shattered outside if he smashed it from
the outside shouldn't have the glass
gone inside probably inside both ways
you've never shattered glass pickles
everywhere well I mean it depends on the
thickness of the glass and all that too
but it so you know these people on the
right were having a [ __ ] field day
with coming up with all these theories
and and crazy [ __ ] of like why this is
so funny and why he had it coming and
it's like
oh
but but that's that's the the what's so
disheartening and what's so sad about it
is that like you're getting dehumanized
because of your political affiliation oh
you're on the left you're a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and you know whatever
happens to you well you had it coming
that's what you get for being a piece of
[ __ ] Liberal oh you're a [ __ ]
conservative that's what you get for
being a piece of a piece of [ __ ]
conservative you had it coming to you
but I will say this
I don't see the left making light of
Misfortune that might come to the right
but at the same time you don't have
crazy people on the left attacking uh
physically trying to attack and harm
these politicians on the right whereas
there was a governor I forgot from which
state who where there was a um they
foiled a kidnapping plan they were
trying to kidnap this uh this woman
Governor uh you know so like the crazy
[ __ ] and the more physical harm that's
trying to be brought on to the
politicians is more happening from the
right side on to the left side
um I don't think there's at least in
recent history during Trump Sarah
there's been like a physical attack or a
physical or a plant to physically
assault or kidnap somebody on the right
side so it's it's it's crazy man it's
yeah I don't know I don't keep up with
any of that stuff all I know is I don't
like any of them like any of you
[ __ ] I don't like any
extremists I don't like anybody without
like some type of reason I don't like
anybody who doesn't like to have a
conversation I don't like any of that
[ __ ] yeah man so it's like somebody who
is hyper liberal I [ __ ] hate you if
you're a hyper [ __ ] let's see
conservative I [ __ ] hate you as well
I hate all you [ __ ] right yeah
it's it's just it's just
um really unfortunate and really sad
that we're in a state where you can't
have a civil conversation about things
anymore I mean we never have to agree on
everything I mean that's just the
reality of the world right everybody's
gonna have different opinions different
viewpoints on things but like
come on man we're still human beings at
the end of the day we should be able to
have a civil conversation about it but
it's not about that anymore it's it's
about tribe mentality it's about oh if
you're not with us you're against us and
as a result then we need to destroy you
know it's like no that's not what it is
man but that's what it's become and it's
and it's [ __ ] up man it's really
[ __ ] up
well I found out something new today I
have no idea that happened to that 80
year old man yeah he [ __ ] bludgeoned
almost to death that's [ __ ] nuts yeah
well guys before we wrap up this podcast
let's talk about the secret society fall
line that's about to drop for those of
you who have been asking about the
genius brain stuff man it's you know the
thing is right with that with that I
don't even get into the specific things
that have happened because they won't
like it'll sound like I'm bullshitting
yeah it'll it'll sound like it's lies
but that's been the situation that's
been the situation guys so much [ __ ]
unexpected unforeseen things have
happened during this process I mean this
was supposed to be a relatively pretty
straightforward production and
fulfillment but you know it it it it in
production you just can never expect
what can go wrong even if you've been in
the industry for a long time which I
have been and I've seen this [ __ ] that
go wrong
these were first times you know these
were first so
it's unfortunate this is not the
experience that any of us wanted you
guys to have especially for first-time
customers like this is the first time
you're purchasing a secret society item
but truth of the matter is a lot of
these things happened and there was
really nothing we can do we we could
have done about it to like expedite the
process and now we're at the Tail land
of the reprodu reproducing everything so
we're gonna hopefully ship before this
week is over today is what today's a
Thursday a Thursday okay so by the time
you guys are seeing this on a Sunday
yeah hopefully shipments have already
happened and by the following week we're
hoping to get most if not all of the
shipments out so it's worth the [ __ ]
weight man it is it is I mean [ __ ] you
guys have might have seen us wearing the
[ __ ] damage pieces you know like we
got all running the [ __ ] for me yeah
yeah
it's dope so it's like you know even
we're we're still rocking it I was
wearing the shirt the other day and then
I I had it hung up I was like damn this
was good I was like oh that thing is
[ __ ] it's not in the center yeah
it bothers me so much I have to ignore
it yeah yeah but you know those are the
pieces we can't [ __ ] send out right
right I just can't we just can't do it
no no it was we we had to do what we did
and it's not it wasn't ideal by any
means but in order to maintain the level
of quality that people have come to
expect from the brand and yeah there was
no way around it so well let's talk
about some of the new pieces that are uh
coming out and fall now in the previous
uh we we've we've uh we showed a few of
the other pieces but there's some pieces
that we didn't get the show yeah uh we
have a tote coming out listen I know you
guys love our bags our bags be going out
oh yeah the bags fast man the Flint bag
and the Calabasas bag like yeah that's
been a hugely uh popular items for us so
talk about about our new tote this [ __ ]
so this is uh upcoming yeah this is an
upcoming tote bag in in our uh elements
fall winter collection
um this is called the Vera article 7
tote bag and you can just basically
think of it as
a giant version of our sling bag of the
Flint slingback so for those of you guys
who are watching it uh through video
um yeah you guys can kind of see it's
it's pretty much the same material it's
nylon
um it's water resistant it's a tear
resistant
um it's pretty good size for a tote bag
I feel like it's really the perfect size
and some topaz be hella big and I
[ __ ] hate it either too big or too
small yeah so this is like right in the
middle it's like the Goldilocks you know
and then so we have our
um logo right there in the front well I
guess you could call either side the
front but yeah yeah um and then our
numbers logo on the other side
um and then basically interior just has
a zipper compartment and then two
pockets on the other side
um straps are adjustable which you don't
see in tote bags and that's one thing
that always kind of bothered me was that
it's either too long or too short and
I'm like ah I wish I could adjust this
and so that's what we implemented for
this so the straps are adjustable you
guys can basically rock it the way that
you want to rock it that's the black one
we also have the white one
um for those of you guys listening
you're just gonna have to wait and see
it but yeah
um yeah basically exactly the same just
in the white version
and is this your first time listening
this is a
contemporary fashion Basics like
streetwear brand we started how long has
it been five years now we started in
August 2017. [ __ ] yeah it's been a
minute it's been a minute but but the
thing is we also had about a two-year
Hiatus period so so I wouldn't call it
like five full years you know three
issues and yeah and um we made our
comeback last November and we're about
to hit that full circle moment with this
new fall winter collection with that one
year mark and one of the things is too
is like uh you know a lot of people ask
you know in my 12 13 years of being on
YouTube I
I don't think I've ever I've only done
merchandise twice right once was when I
first started and it was such a headache
I didn't want to deal with it
um we did we had this brand called go
For Broke which was another clothing
line and that was kind of based off of
like it was like people who I wanted to
represent it was like anybody who were
like dreamers who wanted to push and you
know kind of pursue what they wanted to
do uh we donated that to the Gopher
Broke Foundation
um if you guys don't know what that is
look it up
all the proceeds all the clothes
everything the name all of our IP
everything we gave it to them
um and then
this is this isn't Merch
this is a clothing brand and and it's
hard yeah yeah it's it's this is not a
merch brand by any stretch of the
imagination this is a clothing brand
um and you know it's not gonna be hard
to be able to know that once you visit
the website and you take a look at this
stuff you know and and the again for the
people who are watching the stuff Dave's
wearing right now so the long sleeve tee
is going to be the first time we're
introducing a long sleeve tee we
previewed this in a in a previous
podcast before and we had mentioned it
but I think it's important to reiterate
the t's this time around is a custom
knit fabric so this is going to be one
of the softest most comfortable tees
you're gonna ever buy
um yeah so we knit this fabric ourselves
so this is custom made and then so we're
getting this made here in La custom knit
here in La
um the sweatpants this time around the
difference between uh the elements
collection sweatpants and the back to
basic sweatpants is that we went for a
more tapered look this time around
because we wanted it to kind of be
interchangeable between like a casual
and like semi-formal type look where you
could pair sweats with something that's
a little bit more semi-formal which we
have here right in these knits so these
are knit sweaters uh now cool thing
about this is that part of the content
is from recycled polyester and so like
you know any opportunity that we have to
be more sustainable we're gonna take it
and so when we found out that we can use
like recycled polyester for this program
that's what we did
um and you know just again making steps
towards being more sustainable and
everything that we do is ethical here in
LA right with the factory so
these are the new knits
um super sick these are these are so
soft it's so soft and it's so nice
um and then we have very subtle
embroidery of our logo here in the back
um and then so this is the taupe color
and then we have this which is a heather
gray color and here's the thing too guys
this isn't like
um a solid color you're gonna see
different tones in here to to make up
the color that it's uh that we're
calling it and so this heather gray same
thing here with the logo on the back and
also these items come with the Hang
tacks you're gonna get the SS Medallion
here and then this is just our classic
hang tag and then
um
next color here is the charcoal color
then finally this is probably my
favorite one my favorite color so far is
the Moss color
um between this and taupe are probably
my favorite colors the first one that I
showed you but to be honest all of them
are dope
it's just yeah you guys are gonna
definitely
be happy once you get this feel this and
put it on you know show them the crop
pants the crop is what I'm excited about
the most yeah the crop pants too
um so it's kind of a 2.0 version of our
Chico pants that we did in our first uh
strange times collection which when we
launched I'm actually wearing it right
now for those of you who are watching
um and with this we just kind of
revised it again you know we we kind of
polished I guess so to speak the look of
it and so it's it's a little more
tapered it's a little bit more shorter
for for that clear like cropped look
um these aren't just made short and you
don't sag them to make it they're meant
to be like this uh we have the classic
embroidery that we had the numbers
embroidery numbers logo on the back
we have these hidden Pockets here and we
had bellowed Pockets that were visible
on in the first one but we wanted to
kind of keep it clean here and so we
have the
um the side pockets here instead now so
super comfortable pants
um we are going to have them in two
color ways this black one and this
heather gray one and here's the thing is
that like when we were doing developing
this the heather gray one we're like hmm
you never really see like pants in
heather gray you usually associate like
bottoms and have the gray sweats but we
thought dude it would look pretty
[ __ ] clean if we made you know pants
in that so we decided to go with the
heather gray color here and you'll
notice when you get it it'll be very
versatile in terms of like interchanging
with different pieces whether it's a
simple tea whether it's like one of
these knits whether it's a hoodie a
sweater like it pretty much pairs with
anything I mean that's the cool thing
about those because we're like uh
contemporary like fashion bases yeah
everything from our first line till now
you could wear all everything is
interchangeable everything is
interchangeable yeah and that's that's
what we're trying to do man we're just
trying to get you guys like
great quality everyday items that
literally anybody can wear like all of
our stuff too like I really think that
if for those of you out there who don't
you know like fashion isn't your like
thing right or you know like our stuff
you can build your closet with this and
then for sure build statement pieces
after for sure like that's what I like I
wear my [ __ ] all the time yeah yeah
um that and that's kind of the whole
I guess purpose around why we make what
we make is that it's just something that
you're supposed to be able to wear
anytime every day if you want and again
be have it be interchangeable with
anything and so like you can dress this
up or you can dress this down it's
completely up to you and how you want to
do it and that that's why again even
with the sweats we went for a little bit
more of a tapered look this time around
instead of a bag here because the
baggier sweats look tend to be more of a
casual look more of like a home look or
you're just going out comfortable right
don't get me wrong these are still
comfortable these you know the fabric on
the you know anybody who's bought from
us uh or at least are familiar with the
brand they know that like fabric we
always pay close attention to get trying
to get the best [ __ ] that we can
possibly do
um especially for our price points and I
don't think people understand like just
how hard it is for us to do domestic
production for a lot of our stuff and
keep it at the price points that we keep
it at it's it's a constant uphill battle
but I feel like it's a battle worth
fighting just because we don't want
people to be necessarily priced out of
something because we could charge
technically for what our costs are for
that to 200 plus for those sweats which
is what some of the brands do again some
of those brands are getting it made from
our production house right
but
when even some people might say oh you
know even at 100 something bucks that's
too expensive
but it's not impossible
for some people 200 300 bucks for a pair
of pants might be impossible to get you
know and so yes I know our shit's not
cheap but it's not impossible to acquire
it's not cheap but it's also not cheap
yeah that's the thing there you go there
you go that's the hard thing it's like
how do how how do we work as a company
to show people like Fast fashion has its
place right when you need something
really quick you're on the go and you
know that you're gonna wear this three
four times it's going to obliterate and
you're okay with that that's fine but
the way that it looks the way that it
drapes how long you're going to keep
those pieces is not for long every
secret society piece that I've had from
five years ago I still have and it still
looks good yeah that's the thing about
like fashion fashion Basics they never
die like they're going to be around
forever and the great thing about our
pieces too and I think for a lot of
people who have bought our stuff they
still have it in their closet like I
could bring out the stuff from my closet
right now and you'll look it looks brand
new right right and and that's an
important distinction to make too is
that like yeah we're nothing we're
nowhere near Fair fast fashion fast
fashion or Brands like forever 21 h m
um and you know we can get into that
whole conversation about like how much
of a detriment they've been to the
environment like all the waste and
pollution that they create which is why
they've done so much like damage control
with PR to like oh we're doing the
sustainable program yeah but you guys
are still creating crazy amount of waste
and you know crazy pollution it is
always going to be like that with fast
fashion right there's a reason why like
when you buy stuff at those stores right
and you get it and the next thing you
know you wash it and it disintegrates
and you throw it away and you throw it
away every time I go to a [ __ ] Thrift
place right we go it's all h m [ __ ] and
it's not wearable you can't wear this
[ __ ] yeah so you know understand what
you pay for right and at the end of the
day like you said we understand like
some people will be like it's out of
it's out of my range it's like that's
okay too yeah I I never want people to
break their Bank to buy anything from us
if you see value in our stuff then then
please do yeah right yeah if you see
value love the way that it looks and you
know that you're going to keep it for a
while then please spend it don't don't
save up your pennies and use your whole
bank account for this stuff like I
definitely don't want that but if you do
spend money I want you to let your money
is well spent and it's worth it right
right and I think that's something that
you know I'm always happy about to hear
is that like people who go out on a limb
and maybe they don't normally spend that
much on a team sure I'll get some of the
pieces too yeah yeah so like people who
go out on limb and buy pieces from us
and they might say oh normally we don't
spend this much on a tea or on sweats or
whatever and then they get it and
they're like but this was worth every
dollar that I spent like I can
understand why this is quality and what
sets you guys apart from others these
other brands that they've purchased from
so
yeah this is an item that a lot of
people still want us to bring back which
is the Odin code uh inspired by you know
Japanese kimono and I think it's still
one of the sickest pieces we've ever
made you know
um I still have this this should still
looks brand [ __ ] new yeah yeah this
is like one of the goat pieces for us
you know
um I mean we definitely got to bring out
another coat yeah yeah yeah and and so
like if you guys kind of see the
evolution of our of our brand from like
the beginning uh from when we first had
launched till now like when we had first
launched it was very in line with the
whole contemporary Basics outline uh
concept and then as we have made a
comeback we ventured a little bit more
into Basics into contemporary Basics
because you know at the time we had very
limited resources very limited Manpower
like nobody knew who we were I mean it
was like basically resurrecting from the
dead right and it was really hard to get
a
um to like flesh out a collection
properly just because yeah we didn't
have the resource to put towards it and
so we went more like Basics but now as
we're growing back and and you know even
just speaking on that the momentum that
we've had since we've come back has been
absolutely phenomenal it's been crazy
and it's thanks to you guys it's really
thanks to you guys because we've had
this conversation internally like just
amongst the team like yeah the [ __ ]
we're making is dope but how are people
going to respond to this yeah none of us
were able to know because we didn't know
if our previous customers even cared
anymore if um people even knew that
we're still existing like that's the
hard part too man like and I think for
me
you know one of the most difficult
things about this is that we have to
battle the idea that somebody online is
actually creating a not just like
clothes but a brand that's hard yeah
it's hard like going against people who
are like they're still selling like the
swap the the swap meet [ __ ] sweater
for like 80 bucks and they're like well
how come there's his 80 and yours is 100
It's like because there's not swap meet
[ __ ] yeah like and you know what happens
with these swap me sweaters they're soft
when you wear them you wear them once
they shrink at the waist and the [ __ ]
the fleece on the inside feels like [ __ ]
like this is what we have to battle
though yeah and it's such a it's an
uphill battle but I think it's worth it
and you know when when we get people to
finally buy the pieces they understand
and it's worth every [ __ ] penny yeah
yeah
um and I think that's kind of a
testament to our
quality in our pieces I mean we have
repeat customers because they've
purchased from us and they recognize the
value and what they're getting right and
we always say this man we're trying to
offer you value across the board design
quality price point like we want to give
you the best [ __ ] you can possibly get
for the dollar that you're spending you
know and that's something like I said
that we're always going to try to
maintain it's hard it's so [ __ ] hard
you guys have no because costs are
constantly Rising fabric costs are
rising production costs are rising we
have inflation you know we have a
tariffs that are rising so it's it's not
an easy thing to do but also it's
important that we point that out for you
guys to understand why our price points
are slowly increasing too because in
order for us to grow as a brand like
we're not a non-profit company guys
we're a for-profit company in order for
us to grow we need enough Revenue to
come in we need enough of a profit
margin to come come in so that we can
flesh out our collections more and more
Beef It Up release more things
um but if we keep it at just the same
price point while our production costs
and our raw material costs are going up
it doesn't make sense that's just not
smart business and we're already selling
just to be [ __ ] straightforward you
know we've had conversations with people
who are in a production line who they
see what we make and they see the price
and they're like you have lost your
[ __ ] money yeah if you cannot our own
production guys like bro you cannot be
selling this at the prices you guys are
selling at and I'm like look I know it's
not the
I guess smartest business decision so to
speak but at the same time that's what
is making us different you know and and
that's something that I always wanted to
bring to the market like to fill that
void of like dude we could give you
quality pieces you can buy quality [ __ ]
but you don't have to [ __ ] go broke
or like save for months on end trying to
do that yeah
um so
you know we're trying our best with that
guys and and and we have to like play a
game with it like some items have like
you know better margins than others
because like we're not making as much
here so we need to have a little more
here and then so like there's a
balancing game to this thing but it's
not easy figuring out like a very
competitive price point so far though
um yeah we've been managing and then and
I hope that we're able to continue to do
that and and I feel confident that we
will
um but yeah this this uh fall winter
collection coming out is gonna be kind
of like it's [ __ ] amazing man I'm
telling you like our pieces have been
getting better and better and better
yeah and uh like every season that we
continue to make things it's it's gonna
be dope man like I gotta say man like
this has been a struggle but we do we
definitely make things different yeah
yeah and here's the thing too right is
like with the growth it's not like we're
just sitting back now it's like oh hell
yeah we're [ __ ] growing and making
money and just just like pocketing no
you guys can tell in our output we're
reinvesting all of that [ __ ] back into
growing our our catalog growing our
collections growing our offerings trying
to do it bigger and better each time
like have you ever seen us like with our
major collections
have we ever recycled our [ __ ] right you
know right right have we have we ever
just had the same tea bot like even our
t-shirts we've gotten better and better
and better right every [ __ ] time yeah
like we're putting every cent that we
have back into this business because
number one it's what the brand is about
yeah like we've we've haven't used like
even our last our tea body that [ __ ] was
different from the last one yeah yeah
interesting and and look it's not to say
that like oh our previous stuff is
inferior by any means we're just trying
to constantly improve and tweak on
things you know and so
my taste or taste like it's always
changing right and so like a certain
body that we might have done last season
maybe we feel like okay you know what we
want to tweak it for for this next
season and doesn't mean that that last
season piece is inferior it just means
that's how the thing that's how it's
evolving for us right so even again
going back to this whole custom knit
fabric we didn't have to custom knit a
fabric we could have used pre-made
fabric which is what majority of people
do custom knitting is something you do
anybody on this YouTube space it's not a
majority it's every single well not even
YouTube Just fashion in general right
for me because I was on YouTube okay
yeah yeah every person yeah it's not to
say that they're doing something wrong
yeah I'm just saying that this is the
transparency of like the effort that it
takes for us to create right right right
that using you know already made fabric
is the standard is what I'm trying to
say and like custom knitting your own
fabric happens once you like more well
established we're not
necessarily at a place where we should
be doing something like this and most
people too like I think like when they
start a clothing brand it's just for
them it's let me find this blank and put
my logo on it and that's the extent of
what they're doing yeah so once again
that's not wrong yeah nothing wrong with
it there's nothing nothing wrong with it
but we're always trying to do something
that sets us apart not just because it's
the right thing to do or it's a thing to
do it's just you make better [ __ ] that
way yeah if you want to be a part of
like this Fashion World you have to love
it to the max because this [ __ ] is
difficult yeah very it's very [ __ ]
hard very difficult we're not trying to
pull a Kanye and say like oh I'm sorry
his name is yay we're not trying to pull
a yay and say oh I want everybody to
wear my [ __ ] and then he does like a
[ __ ] Gap collab brand and they're
[ __ ] sweater is 200 yeah you know
yeah top sweater that comes up to your
nipples and it Puffs out you put inside
of a trash bag yeah it's a [ __ ] weird
ass [ __ ] yeah you know what I mean and
look it's not to knock on that there's a
there's a lane for that yeah yeah
there's a lane for that as well but the
point that we're trying to make is that
we we really care about what we do we're
passionate about what we do and we're
constantly trying to improve and grow so
that we can give you guys better [ __ ]
you know because that's a win-win we're
happy with the [ __ ] that we're producing
we're happy with us
um being in line with like our
philosophy with the brand and the whole
point of this brand being created in the
first place and again you guys get dope
[ __ ] in return so you know we we really
thank you guys for your continued
support it's been it's just been
absolutely amazing you know the the
whole team we really feel it we really
feel the love we really feel the support
and our hope is that we can continue to
grow together
um do much cooler [ __ ] because even with
the the shoot that we were doing for
this fall winter collection I had this
like Grand idea in my head and then I
had to stop myself I'm like we don't got
the money for that
because I had a very specific Vision I
wanted to like execute on it but it's
like you know it's that one of those
things where it keeps you motivated
right it's like ah you know we can't do
that right now and I it's not to say oh
I'm disappointed with what we were able
to execute right but it's just like yeah
you have these like I call it fantasies
yeah yeah that when you guys get the
pieces too when you do buy it buy it and
take a photo and then tag us yeah please
guys I want to see it yeah because we're
selling it you know our last step we
sold out of almost everything yeah you
know you got to show us what it looks
like yeah you gotta set put a photo on
there yeah tag me yeah I mean we we want
to see you guys not only just tell us
that you're happy with it show us we
really want to see because it gets us
excited it gets us happy hard yeah and
it's just it's just look one of the best
things that we've experienced is just
like us walking around randomly and
seeing people in the clothes you know
and they might not even know who we are
that's like so cool you know that's like
that's how you know okay it's able to
stand on its own as a brand and and what
we're offering
um so yeah guys just show us we really
want to see you guys in it and you know
if you tag us maybe we'll give you
something in return you never know yeah
who knows
a little something maybe we'll give you
a little gift card you know maybe a
little personal discounts
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast you can catch
Ed
too and then you can catch him also at
s-e-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y secret society uh
follow the Instagram page
um check out what we have uh fall
collection is dropping in November yeah
it's gonna happen and get ready to click
because last time that [ __ ] went out
quick yeah so make sure you guys are
subscribed to our newsletter because our
community members are always the ones
who get first access first dibs to any
new releases that we have and it kind
comes in different forms sometimes will
lock the page up lock the site up and
have a password that's distributed to
our community members and they have like
an hour window yeah to be able to make
the purchases and by the time it opens
up for general public sizes are out
colors are out maybe the whole piece is
out you know so highly recommend that
you subscribe to our newsletter if
you're interested have any remote
interest in what we're offering
um and Dave just mentioned that we're
going to be releasing this elements
collection in November we don't have a
hard date yet we still have to see how
things pan out in the coming days and
then once we have a little bit more
clarity on that we will announce a hard
date of when the release is going to be
but as of right now I would say second
week of November and on that's probably
the time it definitely is not going to
happen in the first two weeks in
November yeah
well guys we'll catch you again uh
genius spring every Sundays at 12 p.m
and we'll see you all next time all
right Joe peace